[Música]
en el último día de visita de estado de
Estados Unidos el presidente de Francia
de Manuel mccoon estuvo en la ciudad de
Nueva Orleans antigua Colonia francesa
donde su gobierno firmó un acuerdo sobre
transición energética con el gobernador
de Luisiana para abrir oportunidades de
inmersión extranjera e impulsar la meta
de cero emisiones de carbono ampliamos
con nuestra enviada especial
el presidente de Bolivia promulgó la ley
del censo que estipula que la medición
poblacional se realizará en marzo de
2024 esto luego de que los huelguistas
de Santa Cruz exigieran la normativa
tras aceptar que el censo se realice en
ese año y no en 2023 como lo pedían en
principio cuatro personas murieron y
cientos resultaron heridas en medio de
la huelga de más de un mes
este sábado inician los octavos de final
en el mundial de fútbol de Qatar el
viernes se jugaron los últimos dos
boletos a la siguiente fase del torneo
Corea del Sur y Suiza fueron los últimos
en sumarse a la ronda de los 16
ampliamos con nuestra enviada especial
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundial soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en la ciudad
estadounidense de Nueva Orleans el
presidente de Francia Emmanuel maccom
finalizó este viernes su visita de
estado a Estados Unidos en el estado de
Luisiana que en el pasado perteneció a
Francia y Dónde quedan unos pequeños
remanentes de ciudadanos cuya lengua
materna es el francés justamente uno de
los motivos de su visita fue reforzar y
Buscar mecanismos para garantizar la
supervivencia del idioma en esa zona
precisamente el mandatario galo habló
frente a personalidades del estado y
Defensores de la francofonía
especial de France 24 nos contó más
detalles de lo ocurrido en la jornada
del viernes
después de ese discurso que ofreció en
el Museo de Arte de Nueva Orleans como
decías con personalidades del mundo de
la cultura y en defensa de lenguaje el
lenguaje y la cultura francesa se ha
sabido y además esto no estaba en esa
agenda que se compartió con los medios
de comunicación que se ha reunido
también con el nuevo presidente de la
plataforma Twitter en lo más un hombre
que ha estado en todos los titulares en
estos últimos días el mismo presidente
Emmanuel macron ha compartido parte de
esta conversación a través de su Twitter
ha dicho que en un momento en el que
Europa en el que Francia Mira hacia la
descarbonización se ha reunido con él lo
más para crear pues políticas
fabricación de vehículos eléctricos y
baterías eléctricas también se ha podido
también hemos podido saber que han
estado hablando también sobre las
políticas de control por parte de la
plataforma para que cuadren para que
comulguen un poco digamos con las leyes
de Europa por ejemplo el refuerzo de la
moderación de contenido o sola o la
protección en la libertad de expresión
Así que desde luego un viaje mucho más
productivo de lo que se esperaba el
gobierno de Bolivia promulgó la ley
descenso que estipula que la medición
poblacional se realizará el 23 de marzo
de 2024 la normativa fue la más reciente
exigencia de quienes se manifestaban en
la ciudad de Santa Cruz y que en
principio pedían que el censo se
realizara en 2023 Pues con él se
determina Cuánto dinero se le otorga a
las provincias Mary vaca corresponsal en
La Paz nos dio más detalles el
presidente Luis Arce ha promulgado la
polémica ley del censo aquella por la
que Santa Cruz ha realizado un paro de
36 días y que permitirá la
redistribución de recursos económicos a
las regiones con base en los datos
censales a partir de septiembre de 2024
y que además permitirá que se
redistribuyan los escaños parlamentarios
antes de las elecciones de 2025
su discurso el presidente Arce ha
fustigado duramente a la oposición
cruceña ha señalado que Durante los días
de paro se han producido muertos heridos
y actos de racismo que no quedarán en la
impunidad por eso ha anunciado procesos
a nivel nacional e internacional para
asentar un precedente en contra de los
responsables de estos hechos el
gobernador de Santa Cruz Luis Fernando
Camacho ha respondido que lo que está
haciendo Luis Arce es Bajar una línea
represiva en contra de Santa Cruz y
además ha acusado a los dirigentes del
partido oficialista de ser los
responsables de la violencia ocurrida
Durante los días del paro Luis Arce
durante su discurso además se ha
referido a la profunda crisis por la que
atraviesa su partido el movimiento al
socialismo ha dicho que existe gente
dentro de sus filas que busca acortar su
mandato y que quiere verlo fracasar de
hecho antes de que Arce promulgara el la
ley del censo el expresidente Evo
Morales ha señalado que el presidente
está a punto de cometer un error
histórico y de hecho morales y sus
seguidores acusan al gobierno de Arce de
haber traicionado al movimiento al
socialismo Al haber aprobado esta ley
porque consideran que es una concesión a
la derecha de Santa Cruz el presidente
delecto de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva aseguró que antes de asumir el
cargo se reunirá con Joe biden según el
próximo jefe de estado brasileño hay
muchos temas en la agenda incluso lo que
ya muestragos causados en la democracia
de ambos países por Donald Trump y Yahir
bolsonaro Lula dijo que definir a la
fecha de su visita tras la reunión que
sostendrá el próximo lunes con el asesor
de seguridad Nacional de la Casa Blanca
Jake Sullivan y aclaró que el viaje se
realizará luego de que las autoridades
electorales le entreguen su diploma de
mandatario electo
y avanza la edición número 36 de la
Feria Internacional del Libro de
Guadalajara en México y France 24 está
presente él emirato de sharjah el
tercero más grande de emiratos árabes
Unidos es el invitado en este 2022
nuestra enviada especial League habló
con el poeta adonis una de las voces más
importantes de la literatura árabe en la
actualidad
la Feria Internacional del Libro de
Guadalajara están viendo sus últimos
días aquí en México una edición número
36 marcada por la participación de más
de 600 escritores de 45 países distintos
y 18 idiomas diferentes y se nota que
este año la feria está mirando hacia el
mundo árabe por primera vez el tercero
más grande de los siete emiratos que
conforman los emiratos árabes Unidos es
el invitado de honor de la feria y del
lado de los artistas algunas voces
importantes de la literatura en árabe
estando presentes como el palestino
Líbano adonis un pionero de la poesía
moderna árabe y es su primera vez en la
feria del libro de Guadalajara nos
compartió su alegría de estar acá
es muy importante tener ferias como esta
porque es realmente un punto de
encuentro extraordinario y casi único la
One
ahí estamos todos de todas las lenguas y
nacionalidades o civilizaciones todos en
la misma casa y eso demuestra que el
hombre puede crear un mundo de paz y
amistad dejemos Las Guerras el
capitalismo y todo eso
capitalismo
después de nueve días de conferencias
charlas y encuentros entre Editores
autores y lectores la Feria
Internacional del Libro de Guadalajara
serárá sus puertas este domingo
finalizamos en Qatar porque este sábado
se juega la jornada 14 del mundial de
fútbol y la primera de los octavos de
final luego de la clasificación el
viernes de Suiza y Corea del Sur este
sábado se enfrentan cuatro equipos
Países Bajos y Estados Unidos y
Argentina Australia Natalia Ruiz enviado
especial de France 24 nos da más
detalles a partir de este sábado El que
pierde se va para su casa comienzan los
octavos de final aquí en Qatar 2022 con
dos partidos el será entre Países Bajos
y Estados Unidos dos equipos que tienen
algo en común es que por ahora solamente
han concedido un solo gol Estados Unidos
que se puede apoyar en una defensa Como
por ejemplo Adams y en ataque con
Cristina Aunque Quizás dependa mucho de
policía y también de ambos ya han
marcado en este mundial por su parte los
Países Bajos pues han cumplido En todo
caso con el contrato que era pasar a
octavos Aunque sin embargo no nos han
mostrado Pues el nivel de juego que
esperaríamos tienen Eso sí a Frankie de
Jong el hacedor de juego en ese equipo y
gappo quien Ya pues ha marcado en cada
uno de los tres partidos esta es la
primera confrontación entre estas dos
naciones y el otro partido será entre
Argentina y Australia dos equipos que
han venido de menos a más en este
mundial los australianos que lograron
derrotar a Dinamarca y sacarlos de este
mundial esa fue una de las primeras
grandes sorpresas que tuvimos en este en
esta fase de grupos mientras que
Argentina logró del electroshock que fue
perder en su partido inaugural ante
Arabia Saudita según La leona la Messi
pues ya el equipo volvió a reencontrarse
ese equipo que que era justamente antes
de llegar aquí a Qatar y también pues
Leonel escaloni el director técnico
parece que encontró ya la fórmula mágica
en el centro de juego con amacallister
con Enzo Fernández y Con Rodrigo de
saber en punta quien irá si lautaro
Martínez o Julián Álvarez en todo caso
Pues esta será la oportunidad para los
zuckers demostrar su buen fútbol
Sabiendo desde que solo uno de sus
jugadores se desempeña en Europa y será
un día histórico en la carrera de Lionel
Messi que jugará su partido número 1000
Así finalizamos esta misión de noticias
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
[Música]